Wayne Hennessey is a goalkeeper for
Crystal Palace a team in the Premier
League soccer story about them yes it is
who got in trouble in January for
appearing to do the Hitler salute as
part of a teammates Instagram photo but
he got off according to this panel it's
called an FA panel three judges got to
decide whether he was guilty whether he
should face any punishment you know from
the league or not because they bought
his argument that he was too stupid to
know what a Nazi salute actually this
was like a team photograph they were
like at a restaurant and I saw the
picture and most of his most of his
teammates are are people of color I
don't know what country they're from but
I would believe that he wasn't really
giving a Nazi salute but I love that
it's like you're too dumb to give the
Nazi salute is it like you got to be
smart like you got to have a PhD if
you're gonna be if you're gonna be a
Nazi in the year 2019 well it said as
you know as improbable as it may seem to
the older generation he seemed to not
even be aware of it when cross-examine
he displayed a considerable degree of
ignorance about anything to do with
Hitler fascism and the Nazi regime well
he's on the panel knowing that being
stupid was his defense how is this how
would that be like an acceptable defense
anyone can just pretend that they're
stupid but how dumb you have to beat of
like I've never heard of World War two
like I think like the Holocaust like I
don't know like and in soccer is one of
the most racist like sports that there
is in terms of the fans I got to think
even maybe more than the NFL but but
yeah the idea that you'll be too dumb
like every single person who gives the
Nazi salute in this day and age has got
to be a moron they lost the war
they are the Confederacy of the
international population that that being
too dumb to do it like if he was like
I'm too smart guys look at what I've
done look at my grades all the way
through
my doctorate I'm too smart to have done
this I would believe that he said he was
calling over a waitress
I mean who calls her waitress like that
well if the waitress was a Nazi then
that makes perfect sense and who was one
of those Nazi themed restaurants you
know what I mean like like Nazis have
you ever been there they got good way
yes it's with an exclamation Chucky
Cheese is a big as a big not Little
Caesars is insane I mean the worst of
all of course is the Cheesecake Factory
I don't want to tell you what goes on in
that Factory but the Nazis love it
it's it'd be dumb know as an explanation
like if that's a usable explanation to
get out of crimes or really any story
like anyone can use it because it really
is the answer for a lot of things like
why did you know a murderer do something
because he's dumb like why did World War
1 start cuz people were dumb like being
dumb doesn't mean you get out of doing
the crime is that what world war one
stone pretty much just a bunch of dumb
reason yeah I'm gonna I'm like why
didn't it why did a certain player's
career not work out maybe he just wasn't
smart enough like like that's the this
is an answer to a lot that happened here
why did I hit that kid on the side of
the highway
cuz I'm dumb I'm gonna run you through
some wars and you tell me why they
started okay alright Revolutionary War
dumb Vietnam War where damn Korean War
Koreas damn war of 1812 just a year was
dumb the French and Indian War World War
one ever I already said that Woodward to
Nazis are down the War of the Roses
warm peace the novel great book but why
did it start dumb reason Tolstoy was
dumb name another war war on drugs the
one drugs George Bush's dump the
actually you're thinking of Reagan you
think the Nancy Reagan
rest in peace all 40 go for dumb what
about civil civil war that was that was
pretty good
that was a good reason was it you
thought the Confederacy was right I mean
they shouldn't they didn't really start
it
moving on but that was good I didn't
have Greg know as much history as he did
but he was a political science major in
college a lot of people didn't know that
about Greg Greg what's the next headline
it's like yeah I don't remember anything
wait were you really I really was yeah
that's I mean that wasn't obvious from
my whip-smart answers to the work was
here the first scan that he looked so
disappointed
our next story is in the field of
gymnastics I just figured we were seven
of em for some funny but like that we
would just nailed the bit in the first
try
the Michigan or former Michigan
gymnastics coach was fired a year ago or
late last year after getting caught in
his car with an eighteen year old
student who was also on the who was on
the gymnastics team the audio of that
arrest came out this week I was having
sex with her in the car he was having
sex with with a lot of the gym yes it
was in a public parking lot then I
didn't say where it was but it was at in
it was the University of Michigan in the
Ann Arbor Police Department found them
having sex in the middle of the day and
she's 18 she is legal but he's like
twice her age and Ruth is 39 years old
he had you know a wife and three kids
and the audio of why in the world would
a 39 year old man a guy around Greg's
age with two kids the way Greg does why
would they want to have sex with an 18
year old gymnast I mean get it together
Jesus the the the story is you know
happened a little while ago but the
audio came out this she's been a great
gymnast she must have done all the flips
that won his heart let's listen to when
he first approached the car
except knocking down the door thanks an
era this is awkward clothes please
that's that the police officer say
letting them know that this is awkward
as if they did not know that it was
gonna be awkward and then I want to hear
how he says how he says goodbye to them
so you know he talks to them he gives
them a little bit of a speech no you can
hear them putting on their clothes play
that real fast you can hear them like
scrambling to put on their clothes
because if you're gymnasts you can get
in that stuff real quick but the guy's a
little older he kind of just tried to
get one pant leg on and just fell over
and then what's the at the end of it you
like well I I just like this was he
tries to give them a little speech but
he can see in the guy's face they're
just you know embarrassed in in right
it's like a it's a ticket it's it's kind
of like a citation in there and they're
obviously embarrassed and he's saying
you know there's not much I can really
say to you and then he finishes it up
this way okay you know what forgive me
if I don't shake hands now is that the
cop talking to the gymnast that's to the
enemy didn't want to shake the gymnast
and because I would be like if I if I
met like a Greg if you were like Anthony
I cheated on my wife with an 18 year old
gymnast first thing I do is shake your
hand you know I mean then bring you in
for a hug I'm like way to go Greg I mean
you would seem a little light-hearted
and too happy about like the dissolution
of my marriage I don't think so I think
listen if you know your wife as well as
I do she would welcome she would welcome
someone she would consider like I think
she considers making love to you like a
chore but if you if you took a lover she
would be fine with it
if you if you were like listen I'm gonna
have an affair with you but I'm gonna
bring the kids with me I'm gonna get two
hotel rooms they're gonna be in one you
have the night off I'm gonna have an
affair you don't think she'd be cool
with that I know I don't think she would
be cool with that or with your with your
attitude here which is kind of like the
cops which like that was the thing that
really struck me with this is
lighthearted he's being and he's trying
to kind of diffuse the situation just
like oh well isn't this you know
embarrassing meanwhile he seems to be
completely oblivious that this is the
moment that both of these people's lives
start to fall apart that basically it's
the end of this guy's career he doesn't
know he doesn't know he's he's a coach
and a gymnast I guess like he just
thinks it's some older guy with a
younger guy but he's he's being nice
he's a younger girl a girl younger girl
a younger girl sorry he's kind of being
like making jokes about it meanwhile the
guy is sitting there thinking my career
is over my marriage is over and this guy
is like acting like he's like sergeant
Winslow on family matters like you know
like making little jokes or whatever
Carl Winslow Carl Winslow I think is I
think is actual name was Carl Winslow I
think his name was sergeant Winslow he
was a second maybe he was Winslow and in
die hard movies that Winslow and not
just uncle's neighbor and I think if you
I think if you're sitting if you get
caught with a 19 18 year old gymnast you
can only be so embarrassed you know I
mean you realize you might be Mike my
career's over but what a way to go out
and if you're a part of USA Gymnastics
in any way they have a pretty high
tolerance for this sort of thing so
maybe he like gets a promotion I don't
know it's also a strange thing that like
if it's an 18 year old the guy's
cracking jokes but it's a if it's a 17
year old he's going to jail mm-hmm it
seems like a fairly arbitrary
line it's the age gradient gray area I
know what I'm saying but like it what
that's a pretty in some states it's not
even 18 like he could be 16 where were
they Michigan yeah I get the legality of
it but if you're thinking about like the
morals or whatever you know I'm saying I
know what you're saying but I think
gymnasts overrules all of that even if
she was ugly he'd still be like gymnast
I'd go for it like if you were like hey
Anthony
I bought a new horse it's a gymnast
maybe I have sex with that horse
you
[Music]